good morning everyone
welcome
as you know the people sitting up here
have had a busy week
with the
committees of conference and
so we're happy to
come to something that is
non-controversial
[Laughter]
so anyhow we'll uh
we'll we'll proceed
um
[Music]
we'll we'll start with the tabled items
i believe that um
oh the minutes first sorry
why do i forget the minutes
always it seems i always do
okay uh could i have a motion to accept
the minutes of our april 15th meeting
thank you senator second by senator
daniels
uh are there any comments questions
thoughts
seeing none all those in favor please
raise your hand
thank you very much
now we move to old business
and um
i understand that
we are ready to remove fis-22129
dealing with the department of safety
and
our question from the last meeting
was that we wanted to see the policy
on uh on how that operated
so
uh if i could have a motion to remove
fis-22
from the table i would appreciate it
thank you
second
all right uh all those in favor of
removing
fis-22129 from the table please raise
your hand
thank you
okay
uh is there any discussion on
this uh request from safety
seeing none
of the item madam cheer thank you very
much do i have a second second
thank you
uh
will the clerk please
call the roll
oh won't you find it yeah
that's okay
okay item 221 129 representative edwards
yes
representative emery paul yes
representative leishman
yes
representative lynn yes
senator daniels yes
senator gray yes
senator rosenwald
yes
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umberger
yes
uh madam chair the vote is nine to zero
nine to zero fis2219
is approved
i also understand that
someone wants to remove fis-134
22-134 dealing with the new hampshire
liquor commission
moving from the table okay represent
senator d'alessandro moves to remove it
from the table do we have a second
second
uh thank you representative edwards
uh
are there any
comments about this or man i'm sure it's
hard to see me down here i don't know
how to get your okay
i'm sorry well
it's a it's a different setup yes sir
yes ma'am so let's vote on removing it
from the table first can we do a
discussion before removing it before our
vote no let's remove it and then we can
just
okay okay
unless well go ahead
i'm easy
so i was just going to ask the senator
what
what conditions did we set when we
tabled it and do you think those
conditions have been met
thank you
yes senator ellis please pull your mic
closer
usually done by problem i know that's
all right
uh yes uh
thank you for the question i did speak
with the commissioner he has
he's spoken with the with the person
that owns the property it's a question
of being power and they're gonna work
they're gonna work things out i think
they've had a conversation with the
governor and at this point in time it's
everything is okay
thank you you're welcome thank you sir
okay
uh could i have a show of hands to
remove fis-22-134
from the table
unanimous
uh do i have a motion to approve fis
thank you do i have a second second
all right who was that
senator gray was that you
represented
it's just i i like to be able to
let people know who did that so
representative edwards uh seconds the
motion
uh will the clerk please call the role
okay
representative edwards yes
represent votes yes representative
elishmen yes representative lynn yes
senator daniels yes senator gray yes
senator rosenwald yes senator
d'alessandro yes senator representative
umberger uh yes
madam chair the vote is nine to zero
vote being nine to zero fis 22 134 is
approved
now in tab three
madam chair before we come off a tube
may
make a point about one of the tabled
items you may
uh
thank you it's it's my understanding
that fs fis22023
related to
the
prescription drug affordability board
that we had asked for them to go through
the rulemaking process before we take it
off the table and
the information i've received is that
no request for a rule review has been
submitted at this point so it's it's
still in stasis
thank you
okay
uh in tab three
we have a letter of
uh from senator reagan
on the legislative performance audit and
oversight committee
relative to the recommendation
uh
to pro for the department of education
oversight on the provisions of special
education
do i have a motion to accept
the requests for audit
thank you uh senator d'alessandro and
senator rosenwald
uh i would just like to say that
this is going to be a huge audit yes
and
as a result
it will be
broken down into segments
that our auditors will um
look at each area separately
so uh we we should expect over time
several reports from
our auditors on uh on special education
so
uh
well the clerk please call the roll
22 200
representative edwards yes
hamrick votes yes representative
leishman yes representative lynn yes
senator daniels yes senator gray yes
senator rosenwald yes senator alessandro
yes representative umberger yes
madam chair the vote is nine to zero
the vote is nine to zero
uh the uh
audit can proceed so thank you very much
okay i have uh several items that
we are going to take off consent
uh or have been requested to be taken
off consent
fis
fis-160
yeah
fis-162
[Music]
fix s-196
fis-1
and fis-198
are there any other items to come up
come off consent senator daniels madam
chair
understand that uh fis 175 has been
withdrawn
that's correct
representative edwards
uh i i only have one question but it
covers two items it covers uh fis 22 172
and
173 but they could be addressed in just
one question
so you would ask that we take those two
off the table or off consent if it's
easier we could just do one
i i don't know if it makes any
difference but it's the same question
for both
items okay if we don't take both of them
off and you don't like the answer that
you receive
then
then you can't you can't retract it okay
yes ma'am i'd like to pull both off all
right
thank you
madam chair
fis 172
and 173
yes
please
okay fis 155.
oh
sorry i i missed that one i thought we
had that one already off
okay
is there anything else to be taken off
the table
seeing none
could i have a motion to approve
the remainder of the items on the
consent calendar
thank you
senator daniels and
senator d'allesandro
okay
oh yes we need thank you all
all those in favor please ri please
raise your hand
opposed
thank you very much
okay
uh
we'll start with tab 4 fis
22 155
good morning for the record marie mullen
from the department of transportation
director of finance
representative leitchman thanks madam
chair and thanks for appearing uh
so on number five on page two
there's some mention about the easy pass
system as you know there's been some
concern by fiscal the number of people
that are
sliding through easy pass and
not paying has there been any more
progress
on
collection or enforcement or
it says in this particular case i have
no immediate effect on revenue however
may improve the ability of system to
collect transactions other than ezpass
so it kind of caught my attention yeah
so
so this particular transfer request is
with our
interstate iag group
and
that's with easy pass and so this hub
that they're creating
will make it easier for us to connect
with other ezpass agencies across the
country so currently we connect with
those on the east coast
and this hub that's being created will
allow us to connect with the midwest the
west coast and those
agencies that use ezpass there so when
someone from another state is coming
through our easy pass we'll be able to
automatically collect those fees without
having to send out invoices and things
so that so that's one that's why it's
not immediate
building that hub will take a few years
and then once that's built we'll be able
to do that
but we've also implemented several of
other areas um we we've added some
additional staff in our collections we
have about 15 staff in our easy pass
collections group
that are going after and collecting
against violators
we've also had a bill this session sb
442 that has been passed by both the
house and senate to try to uh restrict
some of the
the folks who violate that go into a dmv
hold
to be able to um
restrict their ability to kind of a
loophole if they were able to transfer
their title to a family member or
someone else and avoid paying the fees
before they were able to re-register
their car
so that bill once the governor signs it
will eliminate that loophole and allow
us to be able to collect
from these violators sooner and not have
that loophole for them so we we're
always looking at those ways and trying
to prevent the violators in the first
place so we're always looking at
different things we can do to try to
improve the collections on that thank
you thank you madam chair
are there any uh senator d'alessandro
thank you very much madam chair and just
to follow up with the representative
leachman i looked at the little report
that you sent us on delinquencies
and it looked as if
there's five million outstanding is that
still the case
yes that was as of april 30th okay so
five million delinquencies and then on
the other side you've collected
collected over 11 million
and that was over that four year time
frame that's over a four-year time frame
or nearly four years because we're not
done with this fiscal year yet
that was on 463 million dollars of
revenue that was collected so that turns
out to be it's about one percent
outstanding right now
of total revenues that we've brought in
so
so this collections is about one percent
and we're still we still pursue those
because in the law we're not allowed to
um let people
you know we're not allowed to release
the tolls we have to collect the tolls
it's in the law that they're required to
pay so
okay just wanted to make sure everyone
was aware of the fact that there are
significant delinquencies people are
avoiding the tools
and just one if i might one further
question the fact that
the fact that we don't have
the ability to to uh
go through after 10 o'clock at night
you have
you have to
use there's nobody there's nobody at the
toe boat
right so so it's all electronics holding
and that's part of this invoice the
invoicing process so there are there are
multiple ways that folks you know we've
tried to make it easier for them to set
up
um so there's non-cash payments which
have come out and at 7 11 and cbs folks
can go and pay cash and just get a
rechargeable card so their name and
everything isn't associated with it
they can get an easy pass and with that
you get a discount so if you're a state
resident you get a 30 percent discount
if you have an easy pass so we try to
encourage folks to do that because they
get a discount paying cash or
paying through this invoice process you
get invoice and you get another 50 cent
fee on top of the dollar so if they were
to get an easy pass they would actually
have a discount and be paying less for
the tolls so so is it
is it proving to be a worthy use to
eliminate the total collectors from
tenant in the evening until six in the
morning
is is it
is it a zero-sum game or is it a plus
yeah i mean when when we looked at that
we were actually saving money by doing
that the the the volume of traffic
during those hours was not as was not
significant enough to warrant the the
salaries benefits and all the other
electricity and other costs so we found
it to be a cost savings and that's why
we implemented that
thank you thank you madam chair
are there any further questions
uh could i have a mo uh
yeah a motion to accept
fis
22 155 thank you do i have a second
senator d'allesandro thank you uh will
the clerk please call the roll
fis 22 155 representative edwards
yes
represent enrique yes representative
leishman yes
lynn yes senator daniels yes senator
gray yes senator rosenwald yes senator
d'alessandro
representative umberger yes man i'm sure
the vote is nine to zero
vote being nine to zero fis 22 155
passes
we now turn to fis
22 172
and uh
good morning man and chair
of the committee
uh dennis goulet uh commissioner of the
department of information technology
represent edward you had a question i i
i do thank you uh thank you for taking
my question mr goulet uh and thanks for
the phone call the other day that was
very helpful
um
the
uh
the one question i have
for this and the next
is uh
we're moving
software money 221 thousand dollars to
pay for consultants i don't doubt that
you could use some consultants given all
the work that's going on but
i i'm just curious
the 355
between software
licenses not being needed
uh i'm
i must be making a bad assumption about
your process i i would think that we're
still in the first year of the budget
and uh we we should have pretty good
estimates going into a budget on what
our software licenses are going to cost
us and in this case it seems like maybe
we're off a lot or i just don't
understand the scale so so could you
maybe just explain
how we found the money
sure um there's two sides to the
equation and i'll start with the
department of safety item um
that that item we did um we were in the
process of re you know getting ready to
re-bid
those services during the planning
horizon for the budget so we didn't know
and and honestly the
the wage inflation inside the it sector
has has been pretty steep so i think
that contributed to the the bid coming
in higher than we expected
the two areas where we actually had
things come in lower than expected and
allowed us to to do this move
where
one was we actually were ahead of
schedule on a retirement which saved us
some money and licensing money in that
and then the other is a project that was
actually delayed so that we're not
spending it in this fiscal year we'll
start spending it next fiscal year so
that covers the department of safety in
transportation the largest part of that
not spend was scope reduction that
reduced cost of project and and gave us
headroom in order to invest in the in
the wiring
uh there's there's a
additional one where we did a oracle
came in to do an audit
usually that goes the wrong way you end
up spending more money but we actually
found ways to save the state money via
that audit and then so that actually
reduced the cost at
dot did you ever follow it
yes yes ma'am uh i i think mr glade uh
wandered into 173 which i kind of
invited him to but with 173 open i would
want to also know
if
because of the supply chain issues
do we do you want to tell us
whether or not we have any
vulnerabilities to replacing key
hardware infrastructure due to the
unanticipated supply shortages or do you
think we're actually okay even if things
are delayed a bit
uh great question um so
this this committee did approve some
harpa funding in a prior meeting that
allowed us to
really essentially replace the major
part of the executive branch network
we've got a significant percentage of it
i think it's
like four-fifths of it came in pretty
quickly
that last fifth is hung up in the supply
chain um problems
with respect to the uh
fis-173 and the wiring that we would
want to do the the wiring is definitely
particularly fiber optics which we won't
we won't need much of is definitely a
supply chain issue partly because of
supply chain and partly because fiber is
in incredible demand right now and so
it's it's being bought up as quickly as
it shows up
so that could take longer than we want
it to
so so just a little follow-up
yes
so
to get to the the one point
you're not ready to tell us that we have
any critical
shortfalls or risks associated with the
supply chain
i don't anticipate any i what we've done
is we've changed our approach our
project approach so that we can continue
to move forward and and benefit the
state
without waiting to have all of the
equipment in
all right uh thank you man i'm sure
those those are my questions
okay could i have a motion please to
accept
fis-22172
so moved
just a moment can i do both
sure
okay 172 and 173 so moved thank you
representative edwards
thank you representative lynn
second yes okay
uh
you can't do it
well i'll i'll hold off on give you time
i'm caught up you're caught up okay
well the clerk called the role on
fis 172
and 173.
okay this is 22 172. representative
edwards yes
votes yes representation yes
representative lynn yes senator daniels
yes senator gray yes senator rosenwald
yes senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger yes
man i'm sure that vote on 172 is 9-0
okay thank you fis 172
passes
and since it was a dual motion
i will just have the clerk record the
same vote on 173.
wonderful okay
thank you the vote is nine to zero thank
you the vote is nine to zero
and the uh
fis 22 173
passes
thank you mr gillay
uh
we now turn to
fis 1 22 197
office of professional licensure and
certification
good morning madam chair members of the
committee for the record lindsey
courtney executive director office of
professional lace insurance
certification
thank uh thank you
um
repsome leishman
uh thanks madam cheer uh thanks for
appearing so i had some questions on
your explanation certainly i
you mentioned uh acquiring uh more space
uh developing public kiosks however
it goes on to say in the second
paragraph that you've already outgrown
or grown your space so i was kind of
confused on
the whole structure there
yes i agree that we probably could have
made that more clear i think we've
certainly
grown the space the way it's currently
structured um as you may recall
we originally moved from philbrook um
back in i think it was july of 2020.
the initial move was on a 30-day lease
to
approximately i want to say 3 000 square
feet
as that was the only floor that was
available at that time at seven eagle
square
and also um
allowed us to actually execute the lease
um
expeditiously um because we needed to
get out of the building um we
subsequently amended the lease or
entered into a full 10-year lease with
the first second and
third floors
and
if my memory served me correctly that
was approximately uh 20 000 ish square
feet
which was substantially less than what
we had had at philbrook which was
approximately 30 000 square feet um so
we moved into the building with addition
you know with additional staff and we
had when we first moved in phil brook in
um and we had fewer space so when
deloitte vacated that space on the
fourth floor of seven eagle square
we again saw an amendment to our
existing space
or our existing lease to
acquire that space and that was approved
by governor and council of last year
september i want to say it was 15th of
2021.
the way the space was originally
configured
it doesn't it doesn't allow us to use
the space effectively so i would say
that there's sufficient space but it's
not configured in a way that allows us
to effectively utilize the space
i will also say that i think of the
requests uh the renovation line items i
think are in class one
which is
not a significant amount of construction
um that needs to be done in the amount
of 22 000.
further question madam cheer yes please
so with these additional
acquisitions or floors you now have
adequate space at eagle square
i would say with our current uh with our
current staffing we have adequate space
um of course we continue to take on
additional boards
as time goes on so i'm not sure that
that will be the case
you know in the future
if if we can continue to take on
additional
agencies but for right now if we were to
do the construction that is planned and
it really is just to make
two additional conference rooms because
our boards are required to meet in
person
as well as to
create a planned customer service space
our space should be sufficient
thank you thank you madam chair
are there any uh
senator rosenwald thank you i think
that's more question for commissioner
earlinghouse
certainly
oh don't don't leave right
[Laughter]
thank you good morning um to both of you
um director um courtney sent us some
information indicating that the
cost per square foot at eagle square was
something like 22.50
or something
my question is what is the average
state cost
per square foot for
office space how i mean
is it
ever is this on the average side or this
is probably not on the average side um i
so i don't have an average cost with me
and it depends a lot on on uh
you know a lot of the space we lease is
in um
uh is out and about
courthouses for example um and so with
something like we lease something like
15 court houses around the state and you
know the leasing cost is a lot less than
at least in salem for example that kind
of thing so it depends on the location
uh the type of fit up
uh that that's required this space
is downtown concord so it's higher than
the statewide average would be
but when we when we bid the space it was
the lowest available space at the time
and so what what typically happens is
when uh when we have a need for space
and uh this space was originally created
by the
uh the need to close phil brook or not
closed phil brook but to reconvert phil
brook back to its prior use um and so we
moved everybody out and we we um
we looked at space in the city of
concord
um anywhere in the city of concord and
and i think
and don't hold me to this because it's
been a couple years but
uh
something like three or four spaces um
gail rucker at the time was our was our
lease coordinator
um that she looked at and this was the
cheapest of the
three
so
relative to other space we lease and
conquered
then it's higher it's higher downtown
um
you know what i don't know i can get you
i can get you a list of what we pay uh
pay but
i doubt it's a lot higher but i think
it's it's uh significantly
thank you
yeah uh we would appreciate if you would
uh forward that in front i'll do a list
of of all the all the largest leases
that we have in the downtown area okay
thank you
are there any further questions
could i have a motion to approve fis 22
so moved
i don't thank you represent lin do i
have a second
oh okay thank you senator craig
will the clerk please call the roll
fis 22 197 representative edwards yes
votes yes representative leashman yes
representative flynn yes senator daniels
yes senator gray yes senator rosenwald
yes senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger yes madam chair
the vote is nine to zero
the vote being nine to zero fis
22 197 is approved
thank you for
being with us
okay we now turn to
tab 6
fis22160
has been removed
good morning there we go good morning
madam chair members of the committee uh
my name is nathan white i'm the cfo of
the department of health and human
services
and good morning katya fox director of
the division for behavioral health thank
you
mr white
i'd just like to welcome you back to
the budget area
and
i know for for those of you that may not
remember
uh mr white was with the lba
several years ago
and um
is now back in the throes of um
budgeting uh for uh health and human
services budgeting and coming here to
answer our questions so
uh welcome back and we're happy to have
you thank you very much happy to be back
okay uh does someone have who had the
question on uh
fis 160
22 160
dealing with the
988 implementation
okay obviously i i can always ask a
question if you want one no that's
that's quite all right look at this mr
white you come on the on the scene and
everything is perfect okay
uh will the clerk please call the roll
oh i need a motion move the item
second by senator gray
well the clerk please call the roll
uh
representative leishman
fis2216 representative edwards yes eric
votes yes representative leishman yes
representative lynn yes senator daniels
yes senator gray yes senator rosenwald
yes senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger yes and i'm sure
the vote is nine to zero
the vote being uh nine to zero on fis 22
the motion
passes
i'm sorry 160. i was hoping we could
move faster okay
all right
fis22160
is approved
uh
we now are turning to fis 22
162.
yeah i know
good morning for the record joe christie
cfo for new hampshire hospital thank you
good morning for the record ellen
lapointe ceo at new hampshire hospital
thank you very much
uh
represent edwards you had a question uh
yes ma'am i there there are a list of
projects here and i have questions about
four of the projects
um
the the first one
starts on page four
uh item two
make facility improvements based on jcho
standards
as i read that paragraph it says nothing
about what you're really going to do
what standard is are we short in
and and what do we have to do to get
whole
thank you for the question
representative edwards so excuse me
could you pull your mic just a little
bit closer
thank you for the question
representative edwards so this
component speaks to fire stopping in
particular
as you may be aware in healthcare
settings we have to have secure
firewalls and fire barriers within the
facility
so new hampshire hospital does currently
have some penetrations is what they're
referred to by joint commission within
our ceilings and in our walls that could
be of smoke and fire concern if there
ever was
that type of issue within new hampshire
hospital so this component would
address
those areas within the hospital and sure
up
fire stopping capabilities within the
organization it also speaks to some door
closers which also have pertinence in
regards to fire stopping
all right all right thank you that
that's good information
we might want to include that level of
detail in future requests may i ask a
follow-up on yes you may
retain a consulting firm to advise the
department on key aspects of the
forensic hospital operation this doesn't
say how much we're going to spend and
and which which particular key issues we
think they're going to be looking at
because i i believe we funded
the forensic hospital in the last budget
and it was a bunch of money to include
consulting
correct um
so sorry that's okay um so uh
from a dollar figure perspective i
believe we were estimating something
i want to say it was around a hundred
thousand dollars for this this is really
for the operations so we do have the
funding necessary to build a facility we
do have an architecture firm who has
experience in constructing forensic
hospitals but we have no experience in
operating one
and so we're really looking for somebody
to have on retainer who has operated one
of these before to help provide us some
insight as to
things to watch out for
and as well as maybe design
considerations that they would have
changed in the facilities that they had
worked in that we have not yet thought
of so
that was that was the intent of this
uh yes
uh thank you and thank you for the
answer i uh will you be asking them to
specifically take a look at
operationally what the impact might be
on the virtualization of some of the
services
such as
remote cons counseling
those sorts of things are you kind of
speaking in regards to telehealth
capabilities
yes to have telehealth built into it so
that we have flexibility in the manpower
side
i think
in our experience during the pandemic
we've actually
tried some telehealth with new hampshire
hospital
it's very challenging in an inpatient
psychiatric setting to use telehealth
services
part of that face-to-face interaction
and rapport that you build with patients
is actually very important to the care
that we deliver
so i
that's not something we've necessarily
considered
relative to to this consulting
engagement just because in our
experience at new hampshire hospital
it's been very challenging to implement
so so i'd like to just make a comment on
that telemedicine started in
telepsychiatry in
1962 at the nebraska medical center and
dartmouth started doing it if there's
one telemedicine clinical application
that's really been proven it's in the
mental health area so i i would i would
encourage you to push on that because we
could see to a new hampshire hospital as
being both a catcher's mitt for
telepsychiatry
and as a support agency to to promote
out into the community and so i'd really
like to
see y'all
yourselves on the operational side to
play a bigger role in a virtual health
care system
so
i have a different question yes but i
have a question
on this
maybe i'm confused
um
you said that you had no experience in
running
a forensic hospital or forensic
hospital maybe that is whatever the term
is i want to know who's been in charge
of the forensic hospital that's
currently located in the prison i mean
you can't tell me you have no experience
when i thought
that
your agency was the one that managed
what went on within
the
men's prison so the secure psychiatric
unit is that what you're referring to
is part of the department of corrections
so new hampshire hospital does have some
forensic patients within our h unit
however the population that
will be coming to new hampshire hospital
into the forensic facility currently
residing at spu are overseen by
department of corrections
okay sorry i had
had that wrong thank you
uh senator rosenwald you had a question
i did on a
kind of a different
line if i could
thank you
two of the items
number
seven
and
number 12
talk about new furniture in the cafe and
in non-specifically in the hospital
i'm wondering what the current balance
is in the patient trust fund
account and whether
you had considered
covering these costs with that as i
think we've done in the past
thank you for the question and it's a
very good one so um the patient trust
fund uh balance or principle overall
stands at around eight million dollars
we
purchasing furniture through the trust
fund is is
not advised i guess is the best way to
to put it we've done so in the past
really only after a request for
that funding through the legislature
did not make it through the budget cycle
and we felt there was kind of a
significant need to replace those items
in a timely fashion most of the time
it's because there a lot of wood
furniture is still in the hospital wood
is not up to
current standards for infection control
and that furniture can also be broken
and used for object aggression
so we have not gone to the trust fund
for this just because it's really not
been advised
could i follow
certainly thank you so i think the last
time we we looked at this trust fund in
the budget process the balance was about
4 million
dollars it's now doubled
what do we spend that
money on i know it's to benefit
patient experience but
that's a lot of money
absolutely um i think in my three years
here the trust fund has been around
seven million it's now grown to eight um
and the majority of what we we spend
trust fund may fund money on we try to
live on the interest earned every year
and not necessarily touch a lot of the
principle and we do that because we use
a lot of that funding to help with
discharge means for patients so if we're
discharging a patient and they don't
have a pair of shoes or they don't have
a set of clothing or they might need
first month's rent to get them into a
new apartment that's the majority of
what we use the trust fund for today is
to try to help
those transitions into the community for
for patients who don't have the
resources necessary to do so
represent edwards
thank you man i'm sure i'm down now on
item five project five on the learning
management system
and uh i i don't know if mr kane was
able to get some information on this for
us but we had talked uh in prep for this
that um i believe that the the
department of administrative services
ought to have a learning management
system already
and so it made me wonder when i saw this
as a separate standalone project
if
you shouldn't be trying to leverage an
existing lms system that's already
in-house
and then you can expand it if you have
special training that you want included
that's not there today but i i'd hate to
see us going out and procuring another
set of licenses that may be redundant
mr allen house yeah
mr owlinghouse if you
prefer
you can use that mic
yeah that's that's fine
i think they're all working no i didn't
realize they all worked um
and i apologize i think mike probably
emailed me and i blew him off and so
sorry um
you're quite correct that the bureau of
education and training ought to have a
learning management system
um that doesn't mean we do
we've asked for one in the capital
budget for a few years and uh
so far
no takers uh we're asking again this
year
and we're hoping somebody might be
interested in us having one but we don't
have an lms that can piggyback because
uh so far the governor and the
legislature have not
have decided other priorities are more
pressing than that
yes
okay okay that's that's surprising and
lms's core i think to
hr development we we think so too so um
so so given that we're we are probably
on the verge of authorizing an lms at a
departmental level
buried in the bowels of new hampshire
hospital are you able to work with them
on requirements so that we can maybe
expand on their license instead of
finding out in a year when you get some
money for one that we're unhappy and now
we have two
i i think that would actually be ideal
we would love to we would love to work
with them on it
particularly because i'm if i'm a
betting man i bet we don't get it this
year either so
absolutely
okay
excuse me
you're saying that it has to go through
capital
it
it has it's a it's a very large expense
and the odds of anybody adding it to our
operating budget are very slim but
you know new modules of the erp and
things like that are always done through
capital yeah i mean what i get what i
can do and i don't mean to be smart
alecky about this um what i can do is um
is that um we'll talk to them and we'll
uh all of us will talk to dennis
okay
sounds good thank you very much
mike my question
my next one was on uh 12 and senator
rosenwald
sort of teed it up a little bit
um
my challenge is i i work on the low on
the rockingham county long-term nursing
home and and on division iii and so i'm
confused uh because i don't remember in
which budget
we made a point of adding money for new
furniture
um what did did we did we not in
division three add money specifically
for new furniture
not in the most recent budget cycle no
all right so
um i'm just confused then
um and then if i could just make an
editorial comment on page three
sort of in the middle there the phrase
reimbursement is typically a fraction of
the cost
i
just being literal everything is a
fraction of a cost whether it's greater
than 100 percent or lower than 100
percent so that phrase means nothing
except it frustrates people like me if
if if instead of writing that sort of
language if you could maybe insert a
percentage
of course all right so that's just
editorial thank you
are there any further questions
represent or senator d'alessandro thank
you mr while they're here what what's
the status of
the hospital at this point what's the
wait list at this at this point in time
thank you for the question so currently
our waitlist as of this morning our
queue was at 25 patients
for the question about object
let me recover from that answer please
it's a tough one
and and the the monies that have been
appropriated to renovate the building so
that we could accommodate more patients
where do they stand that was in the last
operating budget before this one
we put we put 5 million in there for
renovations
so we currently have not had the ability
to utilize those funds to start
renovation projects are you you're
speaking of the enf renovation right
further question about upgrading
i'm not sure i understood your answer
okay
i mean
to
senator d'alessandro's question you said
you haven't been able to utilize those
funds not yet we haven't been able to
start renovation projects however the
so we do have a unit um that isn't being
occupied within enf help but the other
half of the unit is being occupied right
now by adults and is full
this has been a a concern of mine for
for years now
just one further question what's what's
the length of time with the wait list at
this point um well
through a lot of really great work
lately we've been able to get our wait
list down um in the past in the two
years that i've been there i've seen
folks waiting on the list for upwards of
two weeks however more recently we've
been able to get patients in within um
three to i mean sometimes even two but
probably two to five days
it would further question
um
it's
kind of escaped my mind as we as we
watch going through this
but um yes it
if you were able to hire
all of the vacancies that you hire i was
told by your precursor that we would
have no wait list
is that still a correct statement yes
that's still accurate
thank you thank you
senator rosenwald thank you
when i look at
the waitlist data that the department
keeps
sometimes i see that the cypress center
has half of its beds
available
and still we run a wait list of right
now it's 25 last week i think it was
10 more maybe higher than that
why are
the those patients not appropriate for
the cypress center um
i'm
well i can't i can't speak specifically
to cypress center but i think my
understanding of what makes it
challenging for those other admitting
facilities is also a staffing issue so
when we see some of their beds come
offline it's because they're having
staffing challenges that they have to
work through before they're able to take
more patients off the queue
are there any further questions
representative leishman thanks madam
chair i would just wonder if you could
tell us why the renovations you said
they you haven't gotten to them but why
not
um well we've had difficulty from a
census perspective trying to maintain
the balance between
admitting in the queue
and really
making sure that patients are able to
get into new hampshire hospital as
quickly as possible
while
then also moving forward with a
renovation so we haven't been able to
find that balance yet of being able to
renovate the unit and still maintain
where we need to be from a cue
management perspective
represent blinn
can i just follow up on representative
leachman's uh
uh question i guess i'm not i'm not sure
i understand the connection of
i mean i understand the two things that
you're talking about but it seems like
the people who would
would be you know
doing the work to
get a renovation in place would be
different
from the people who would be trying to
decide you know to
make sure that there are
make sure that people are getting that
for the facilities that are currently
available people are getting in
as quickly as possible i mean i
i guess i'm i guess i'm not sure i see
the connection between those two and i'm
wondering if you could elaborate a
little bit
um sure i can i can give it a try it's
really
about capacity and if we are
taking a unit offline to be able to
perform the renovation then we
are taking beds offline that currently
are being filled and occupied by adults
okay i'm sorry i thought you had said
earlier that there was a unit that was
not
being used and i guess i was just sort
of assuming that that would be one of
the places where the renovations were
made and if if that sounds like that
assumption was incorrect
we do have a unit offline and that's due
to staffing currently
okay
which might
again might suggest to me that maybe
since that you can't staff that that
that might be the place where somebody
who knew about renovations would be
doing the renovations
so i can take that back to the
commissioner and talk a little bit more
about the status of that project
you know i think any renovation project
new hampshire hospital would be very
grateful for and as of right now we just
haven't been able to find that balance
with the q management
thank you thank you very much
are there further questions
i do have oh yes go ahead
part of what we
did in the
budget a few years ago
was not only to fund renovations of
that unit but also to increase
transitional
housing
money to
um solve the backdoor problem what is
the status of those transitional beds
across the state i know we opened the
ones at philbrook
but
have we funded all of the
i think 30 or 40 beds that we funded
to
open up
the beds for the acutely
ill
gotcha just just sit down
at one of the
yeah
uh absolutely not the cameras are with
us all over the place
again for the record i'm katya foxx
director of the division for behavioral
health and i'm sorry my back is to you
um
and we did provide that information i'd
be happy to provide it additionally i
don't have it here today
of all of the housing and the amount of
housing that we've seen increased
and we have used that housing
funding
that was afforded to the department for
that purpose
for a number of beds across the state
and again
i know that
we presented before hhs oversight
committee and we'll be happy to provide
that of information again
thank you very much
we'll look forward to
to receiving it
one other question i have
and that is the five million
i
was that out of capital or was that out
of
general funds
the
i'm sorry the 5 million in
relative to this item
yeah relative to the construction
it was general funds okay the the
renovation of the unit yeah yes okay
so we have
what 13 months
so we best get moving
we we have um begun all of the design
work around those projects so we we um
although the construction hasn't
necessarily started a lot of the design
and architectural work has has begun and
connects well thank you but you need to
you need to get to the construction so
you can
save it off for
the next budget because i don't want
that to lapse
you know understood
okay
all right are there any further
questions on um
this particular item
i know we kind of
went all over the place but uh
thank you um
i'm not sure
it's been a long time since we've had
the uh
the hospital in to talk to us so
we probably had a lot of questions that
yes
did you have another question uh yes
please okay uh item 10 uh just caught my
eye as you were talking
it looks like we're going to spend money
on uh improving signage to make them ada
compliant
um given that we're building a uh a new
facility is this just wasted money i
mean it it brings us to into compliance
for
a few months but but signage is unique
to the structure so i'm just wondering
if this is a waste of money thank you
for the question um so no
it wouldn't be a waste and really the
current signage within new hampshire
hospital
is not sufficient to even our current
state we still have signage within the
facility that refers to the anna
philbrook center
that used to reside within new hampshire
hospital so it's greatly needed
throughout the facility and then
signage that is specific to the forensic
portion of the hospital would be
incorporated within the construction and
build of that specific facility
can i have a motion to approve
fis
um some move madam chair
thank you 162. thank you
second by representative lin
will the clerk please call the roll
22 162 representative edwards yes
hamrick votes yes representative
leishman yes representative lynn yes
senator daniels
yes senator gray yes senator rosenwald
yes senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger yes madam chair
the vote is 9-0 thank you uh the vote
being nine to zero on fis 22-162
is approved
we now turn to tab 7
fis22196
okay sorry
um someone have a question on
representative leishman
thank you madam chair and
i'll echo what the chair said mr white
it's nice to see you here uh
for those of you that don't remember he
helped us out in division one for a
couple of terms and made us all look
very good so
it's nice to see you
uh my question and thanks for appearing
uh
the notice of award doesn't seem to
match up with your request
um
am i misreading something there there's
the total the uh award bonuses
the numbers the amount of federal funds
obligated by the action again don't seem
to match up with the department's
request so i wonder if you could help me
out with that sure so um this is a bit
of a unique scenario um
can i borrow that for a second sorry
i've lost my papers up here already
wait a minute
right
so so this this is a bit of a unique
scenario where
the the prescription drug monitoring
program
was transferred over to the department
of health and human services during the
budget
um the the second year
uh was not budgeted uh completely it was
only budgeted at 255 000
um and what we're seeking to do here is
the we're seeking to sure up the entire
budget for the full state fiscal year
similar to what we would do
throughout throughout the course of the
normal budget process
i can't really speak to why the original
budget was only 255 000 and not the not
the full
almost 1.5 million
so if i could man i'm cheering if if i'm
looking at
there is a surveillance prevention
and it's like 3.6 and again
you're only requesting 1.2 with the
request so i'm still not quite
following you on this
sure sure um
so so so just from uh
maybe it helps us to kind of almost take
a further step back so for state fiscal
year 2022
for this program we received the the
budget was appropriate and it was full
what what we're seeking to do here is
add the additional one point
1.2 million dollars here
to to make the the budget for state
fiscal year 2023 what it should have
been
in the original budget
we received the budget from oplc it was
transferred over during the budget
process and and it was not completely
funded
i i guess i'm still
i had a loss of madam chair but okay i
appreciate your cause i'm just looking
if i could take this further the award
ending date is 8 30 1
22 and yet your request goes through
june 30th of 23. so that's that's what
caught my attention understood i
apologize uh representative leishman yes
so we we have received notice um from
from the federal awarding agency that we
will be receiving the second award here
uh it should be happening next month uh
if not in july you're referring to the
award that that ends in august included
in right that was attached to the yes
request yes yeah and that other award
will be coming so what what we're
seeking to do here is is following the
same approach that we would follow
during the budget where we would budget
the the appropriate amount um for the
year and then we would receive those
funds at a later date
all right so it's just we haven't
received the notice of reward that
you're referring to in the request
correct okay thanks thanks madam chair
are there any further questions
okay seeing none uh well the clerk
please call the roll
oh i need a motion
okay so senator d'alessandro and uh
senator rosenwald
okay
22 196 representative edwards yes eric
boats yes representative leishman
i'm going to vote no madam chair
uh representative lin
yes
senator daniels yes senator gray yes
senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umberger
yes
madam chair the vote is eight to one the
vote being eight to one
fis-22 196
is approved
okay before we move on to
section eight
i want to remind everybody
that use june 30th 2022
as the time that their request they were
going to
spend all of the money
that they requested
do not
come back to me
you made the decision
that that money would be spent by 30
june 2022
so
i am
not
going to
think about those
i'm asking you to think about how you're
going to do that in the next 45 days
okay
so
because there were a lot of requests
in there that had
30 june 2022 dates
so
just a fair warning
okay
we now move to uh tab 8
and
the first item that is off is
fis22161
are there questions uh senator rosenwald
thank you
so um
this item
has to do with
helping people who are elderly or who
have disabilities
schedule
the covid vaccine appointments
i think
as i understood it and i'm
wondering
are these medicaid
beneficiaries and
if so why
are the mcos
or area agencies
not
able to do this work
is it outside the scope of their
contracts and
really why does the state
have to take this on
what sorry i thought i was put thanks
nathan see teamwork chris santaniello
associate commissioner so um thank you
for the question senator rosenwald and
i'm trying to get around this piece of
equipment okay um this is actually to
help
will occur in our service links across
the state
so
some people with disabilities would get
support from the area agency but the
service links
or their managed care organizations or
whoever is serving them but the service
links serve a broad range of individuals
and families with disabilities um
and who are aging there's about 70 000
people a year so this is really
broad-based
across the community for those seniors
that do not have the support of another
organization
are there further questions
seeing none could i have a motion to
approve
senator d'allesandro do i have a second
second
uh representative lynn
will the clerk please call the roll
22161 representative edwards yes emery
coach yes revision leashman yes
representative lynn yes senator daniels
yes senator gray yes senator rosenwald
yes senator d'alessandro yes
representative member yes
madam chair the vote is nine to zero
the vote being nine to zero fis-22
161 is
passed
okay our next one is that's off the
calendar is
fis22198
someone have a question on this
i man i'm sure yes i i think edwards i
think what we wanted to do in pre-fiscal
was just uh just to hear the dialogue on
the process of how we received this
money how we got the profit and and how
we're teeing it up for reuse in a
subsequent time frame i i think we
wanted the story
yes
that's correct
good morning uh for the record my name
is ian watt i'm the deputy director for
the division of public health services
so when we had initially requested
funding for this item we
were in the middle of the omicron surge
this winter and had worked with a vendor
and a series of vendors there was a
competitive bid to
obtain antigen tests for sale at the new
hampshire liquor stores
we had anticipated being able to sell
all of the tests in the liquor stores
there was an immense shortage nationally
and in the state they weren't available
anywhere at the time
we actually initially wanted a smaller
uh procurement but we weren't able to
get a competitive bid for a smaller
number which is why we were able to
procure or ultimately procure a million
tests uh those tests have been for sale
since january in the liquor stores what
happened was simultaneous to the award
and receipt of those tests there was a
confluence of a few events first of all
the federal government initiated their
free to your front door test program
which was good news for people's front
door but not good news for demand for
these tests uh there was also a shoring
up of the national uh supply chain and
tests so they became available at big
box stores and retailers and pharmacies
where they weren't otherwise so as a
result we did not see the demand that we
were anticipating
the tests have been on sale at the
liquor commission since since january
and as a result we're looking to
reallocate and reappropriate some of
those resources to other known audiences
that have demand that we've been
providing tests to uh to support their
operation safe operation continuation
uh yes representative edwards
uh thank you for the
explanation i i'm just curious as you're
looking at other potential buyers for
the excess inventory that we have
um could you could you like tick off a
few of them um
i i'm just i just want to make sure that
we aren't um disposing of them or
reselling them to some nerdy well
organization
so
so thank you for the question so the
intent is actually not to uh sell the
items the intent is to use them for some
of our audiences to whom we've been
providing tests
for public health
and safety reasons so the audiences that
we're proposing as are noted in the
letter are
federally qualified health centers fqhcs
hospitals
camps to ensure the safe operation of
camps this summer our schools as well as
the public health networks who support
first responders and others so these are
audiences that we the state have been
providing these antigen tests to um via
via federal allocation and other funding
sources so the intent would be to
repurpose these uh for a known need uh
that we have and have been providing
throughout the pandemic
so one other yes following
so um i i i heard the confluence of
events and i understand all that i i
just wondering if in
retrospect if you think
that we uh that there was anything
fundamentally wrong with our estimation
process to begin with or just stuff
happened
yeah i think it's a good question thank
you
you know we
hindsight has been very valuable
throughout the pandemic as we know um we
at the time did have the question both
internally and and i believe even from
this committee of if a smaller number
would make more sense as a starting
point what we found when we went out to
the vendor community is that no one
would entertain a smaller number and
that was because the competition was not
just our state many states and other big
corporate entities that we're trying to
procure for them their own sake um you
know again competition has been been
fierce and when that's been fierce um
you know vendors have been able to to
leverage to to turn to the numbers they
want
so we picked a number that we thought
and do still see demand for it just
didn't didn't materialize in the liquor
stores
are there any further questions
seeing none could i have a motion to
accept
if i
okay thank you
second
clerk call the roll please
22 1988 representative edwards yes
eric's yes representative leishman yes
representative lin yes senator daniels
yes senator gray yes senator rosenwald
yes senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger
yes madam chair the vote is 9-0
fis
22-198 is approved nine to zero
we now move to tab 11
fis22168
are there any questions on these
transfers that are being requested
seeing none
could i have a motion to accept
thank you do i have a second becca thank
you represent lynn
you ready
clerk call the roll on fis 22
168. 22 168 representative edwards
yes henrik votes yes representative
leishman yes representing glenn yes
senator daniels yes senator gray yes
senator rosenwald yes senator alessandro
yes representative umberger yes madam
chair the vote is 9-0
the vote being 9-0 on fis 22-168
is approved
we now turn to tab 12
fis22169
[Music]
and this is
authorization to oh change the date
to 30 june 2023 thank you
and make some changes in class lines
are there any questions on this item
seeing none could i have a motion to
accept
thank you
second
senator gray thank you
are we ready yes will the clerk call the
roll 22 169 rosie of edwards yes
memory coach yes representative leishman
yes andy flynn yes senator daniels yes
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umberger yes man i'm sure the vote is
nine to zero
the vote being nine to zero fis 22-169
is approved
so mr white you did pretty well today
i give the credit to everyone else okay
thank you i'm glad you're here
okay we now move to tab 13
[Music]
fis-165
fish and game
authorization to transfer 235 000
from the fish and game reserve to the
fish and game operating budget through
june 30th 2023
are the item thank you representative
leishman do i have a second
thank you senator d'alessandro
clerk call the roll please 22 165
representative edwards yes cameron
representative leishman yes
representative lynn yes senator daniels
yes senator gray yes senator rosenwald
yes senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger yes madam sure
the vote is 9-0
the vote being nine to zero fis 22
dash 165 is approved
we now turn to tab 14.
fis22166
authorization to
transfer 200 000 from the new hampshire
fish and game
fund reserved to fish and game operating
budget
so are there any questions on this
i just i just yes is anybody from
fishing yes they are
uh for the record i am scott mason
executive director fish and game
thank you mr mason nice to see you as
always uh just wanted an update on the
hatcheries what's going on there how
many hatcheries are we going to save
and how we gonna do it
well we have uh
a plot we received the 55 million for
money uh we are currently
working with hdr they're an engineering
firm and we're going through a study
process and looking at our hatcheries
trying to inventory resources to make
that decision
on exactly how many we'll keep and where
they'll be
for the question and what will we have
with the answer
um we should we're hopefully going to be
able to start on on
the completed
study won't be done until december but
we do believe we're going to be able to
identify assets that we could begin the
process of designing um replacement
hatcheries in those locations
prior to that
it
went for the question now how about uh
the production of the hatcheries for
this for this season people love fishing
licenses want to know if stocking is
going to take place is that going to
take place
our goal um our goal is to try to
maintain production as best we can
through the construction process
um we
will probably be staggering our
construction so that uh we can try to
maintain you know maybe beef up a little
bit of extra production at some of the
other hatcheries while we're working on
on one on the hatchery we're working on
thank you
thank you thank you but but there's no
effect on fit there's no effect on fish
those who have bought licenses obviously
but but there's no no effect this year
there'll be no effect this year um
i would think it would be
it'll probably be in um
calendar year 24 when we will really
begin and that's when we we may get
pinched on production
thank you
are there any further are there any
further questions
seeing none could i have a motion to
accept fis-22
senator d'alessandro do i have a second
by senator gray
will the clerk please call the roll
22 166 representative edwards yes henry
quotes yes
representative leishman yes robbie's
andy blinn yes
senator daniels yes senator gray yes
senator rosenthal yes senator
d'alessandro yes representative berger
yes
the vote being nine to zero fis 22-166
is approved
now turn to tab 15
fis-22
and this is a request from the judicial
council
to approve
595 thousand dollars
through
june 30th 2022
are there any questions
seeing none could i have thank you
senator d'alessandro do i have a second
second
representative lynn
oh you know all about these guys
hello the clerk please call the roll 22
186 representative edwards yes everybody
yes representative leishman yes
represented lynn yes senator daniels yes
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umberger yes manager of the voters nine
to zero
the vote being nine to zero fis 22-186
is approved
we now move to tab 16
authorization to transfer 2.4 million
dollars
uh in unexpended funds from registration
fees
for
ohrvs
all right are there any questions oh
could i have a motion please
thank you do i have a second
okay
representative lynn
are there any questions
seeing none
will the clerk call the roll
22-167 representative edwards yes henrik
votes yes representative leishman yes
representative lin yes senator daniels
yes senator gray yes senator rosenwald
yes senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger yes man i'm sure
the vote is nine to zero
the vote being nine to zero fis 22-167
is approved
we now turn to tab 17
fis-22
and this is to
modify the snap education and training
program
and accept and expend
230 thousand dollars in federal funds
could i have a motion
to accept
move to accept okay
move base representative edwards
seconded by senator d'alessandro
are there any questions
seeing none will the clerk please call
the role
221-170 representative edwards yes
cameron's yes representative leishman
yes representative glenn yes senator
daniels yes senator gray yes senator
rosenwald yes senator alessandro yes
representative umberger yes madam chair
of the vote is nine to zero vote being
nine to zero fis 22 16
has been approved
okay we now move to uh our information
items
madam chair yes uh there is a late item
oh
sorry that's 22 205. that's my fault i
apologize
the late item is uh from um
doit
i know uh it was sent out
uh
could i have a motion to approve
senator rosenwald second thank you
senator gray
are there any questions on
fis 22 205
madam chair yes
um just just a moment
mr goulet would you mind thank you
good morning again
go ahead so so i'll admit that given
that this was a late breaking item i've
not read it and so
what i'd appreciate mr gilley doing is
just walking us through what this
request is and and why we're receiving
it now
sure thing
um
so this was this request was driven by a
couple of a couple of things one one was
that
during our
coveted response and recovery activities
we really could have used this
capability we were standing up sites
really quickly and in some cases we were
trying to operate without
very good network connectivity at all
so
when looking at
when looking at the ability on the
public health space to do this
we thought it was important to have this
capability we could stand up a very high
quality
wi-fi network that could span over a
large geographical area and handle a
very very dense population of users
for that purpose so that's that was one
of the design criteria
um
and um
iran or not ironically coincidentally
that very same design criteria
is a perfect fit for some um non-state
events that we could potentially support
the one that we are targeting and
highlighting in the request is the um
the craft fair at centipede that's run
by the league of new hampshire craftsmen
they've gone from
historically the
uh the entity that was leasing the
centerpiece space had pretty high
quality wi-fi that was covering that
area and so
it wasn't required as an additional
thing
um with the the veil um lease
part of their shtick or how they like to
operate is to not actually have wi-fi
there have to be an outdoor activity so
they actually pulled all that stuff out
of there which was you know i'm not
aware that it impacted much except for
the craft fair it impacted extremely
heavily
so i ended up
getting a reach out from them and asking
for help with that particularly after
last summer's event that didn't go well
from a network connectivity perspective
i apologize for the late item the timing
was such that
you know it was it was approved to go at
a very late date
and and i'm concerned about supply chain
issues so i'm trying to get this process
as quickly as possible so i do
appreciate your indulgence on this late
item
no problem are there any further
questions
okay
no we already have motion
well the clerk please call the roll
22 205.
uh eric beauchess representative
leishman yes representative yes
senator daniels yes senator gray yes
senator rosenwald yes senator alessandro
uh representative
umberger yes
man i'm sure the vote is
7-0 the vote being seven to zero fis
22-205
is approved thank you
thank you
okay we now move to uh
the informational items um
i want to point out that um
we have two people from
the audit side of lba that
mr kane is
recommending um
step increases right so okay just that's
that
um
details of fund balance that
dis provides to us
i realize that this is an arduous task
and i thank you for
what you're doing
but
over the summer
i would like to
get together with you and the lba and
see if there isn't
some way that we can
make this report
a little better
than what it is today
i don't know how many
others of you have looked at it but um
anyhow
um
i
i also
will uh request
you know i'll i'll
get it and that is
to come and talk to me about the um
employee health insurance
because i'm i still have
i still have questions
in
all of that so we'll
we'll do that
sometime as well
okay
um
the next one is fis22189
and i see that uh
commissioner edelblut is here and i
would like to ask a question
on
childhood lead poisoning
i might
for the record frank edelblut
commissioner of education
and brandon kernan administrator of the
drinking water and groundwater bureau at
des moines thank you
as i read through the report
i am very disappointed
in
the schools that are reporting
you know i didn't i didn't see a lot of
movement on that and i know that this is
an issue that we've had for
several years we've put money into it
any number of things
so
i guess that um
we need to we need to try to up the
number of schools and day care centers
did we pass that bill
on
unlead and reporting
and that's the one that
that requires the schools to report
is that correct
i think they've already been to work
right but i had to report the test and
yeah report that that bill
lowers the
oh the threat just lowers the threshold
yeah go ahead i'm just
i just think it's unconscionable
that our schools and uh daycare centers
are
just
not doing a good job with this but
thank you representative yes
[Music]
house bill 1421 did go through
conference committee in addition to
lowing the action level for schools and
child care facilities from 15 to 5 parts
per billion
it really strengthens a couple things
that i think will inspire people to
react and also make the department more
aware if they do
one thing it does is it has very
explicit
parental notification requirements now
instead of just a general statement you
shall notify guardians and parents it
talks about direct notification
and also
posting
but it also now says clearly that you
have to report all sampling data to the
department environmental services prior
to that we only had to see
the results that were exceedances um and
so now we'll have access to all the data
another thing to remember is although
the legislation and funding was
established a few years ago it was only
staffed about a year ago with a
part-time person funded by a federal
grant and then a contractor just came on
board the last few months
and so there's a lot of activity now in
getting the word out to schools and
child care facilities we're learning a
few things though the number of grants
here don't reflect necessarily
inactivity from schools and child care
facilities
the way the law reads is they have to
sample pretty much any fixture that
could be available for drinking water
and sometimes they're just sort of
abandoned sinks in a classroom that's
not really used and so it's easier just
turn off the water into the sink because
no one's using it and that's why the
result might be high because it's a sink
that hasn't that has stagnant water in
it
and that's the kind of data that we're
trying to capture with our contractor
now there's no reporting mechanism built
in necessarily to show that
but now
we're going to get all the data we will
be able to respond to those exceedances
the other thing that's happening
is that this and i think it's on admin
services website now there's a request
for proposals to establish free testing
services for lead for schools and child
care facilities
and that's again funded with a federal
epa grant and so that'll make it more
accessible for those facilities to
readily sample and not worry about costs
and budgets
and
i guess the
the last thing that we're contemplating
and still having discussions is
wondering about possibly tweaking the
parameters of the grant we know some
facilities are opting to
address a 500 1 000 problem without
seeking reimbursement through the grant
just because of the extra administrative
work it's not worth their while
so
you know i'm pretty optimistic about
them that these facilities are
responding to the data
because you know
they're in the businesses they care
about children i just don't think we
have the mechanism until now and we
still need to figure out the staffing
because house bill 1421
didn't include money to administer it so
we're going to try using more federal
funds to hire
another part-time person
or more contractors because at the end
of the day we have 1500 new entities we
have to essentially regulate and about
30 000 compliance points and we're doing
with a three-fourths of a staff person
and a contractor so a lot of this is
really needing the schools and child
care facilities to cooperate and do the
work because we're not going to have
this big regulatory regime in place over
them
let's hope not
representative or senator rosenwald
thank you madam chair
um so for about three years or so
schools um and child care facilities
that
have tested
and and found that their drinking water
has greater than 15 parts per billion of
lead in it have been required to
remediate why is it that only 51
of the
schools that you list above that
led content
have remediated
and i i asked this knowing that we took
the enforcement provision
out of house bill 1421.
so i'll let des comment as well but what
i can tell you is that in many cases um
when the schools have had a hit
so they've identified a
um
you know some water source that had and
it may or may not have been used for
drinking water so i just want to be
careful because sometimes it's the
janitor's closet as well
but sometimes when they discovered it
they just remediated them it remediated
that themselves many of our schools have
switched over to water bottle filling
stations as opposed to drinking
fountains they had already had those
projects in place and they went through
that
and that would have solved that problem
but rather than go through the process
of applying through des for the
remediation plan they just did it
so a lot of that remediation has taken
place even though it doesn't reflect in
the reported numbers and i think des
should comment as well
yeah that that's correct i i'm
pretty confident the majority of the
exceedances have been addressed and
again
not everyone felt the grant program was
worth their while that they could it was
just easier to mitigate the problem
without the state funding and the state
paperwork involved i mean one thing we
can do
and again we have very limited staff is
reach out to the exceedances and ask
where they haven't told us
how they've mitigated it or if they've
deactivated that that fixture and we can
try reporting that back to you
um
thank you so
how
if they're not reporting that they've
remediated
what makes you confident
that
the majority of them
have remediated
those
outlets over 15 parts per billion
well i have a lot of confidence in the
education system and the people that
work in it
i
actually have two brother-in-laws a
spouse and a sister-in-law all work in
school
systems and
have seen when there's a water quality
issue be a high fluoride level or a lead
level and seeing that they've take
actions to notify people
and to mitigate the problem
yeah there's probably somebody out there
that needs a little more oversight and
nudge but i'm confident in general the
people in this the sector are addressing
a high lead level they unders they if
anyone understands what lead can do to
children
so the only and i would just comment um
senator relative to that is that
you know um
again i don't i'm not sure that sort of
that but another perspective might also
be i mean i know at the department of
education we have repeatedly brought
this to the attention of our school
leadership
you know through written notifications
and you know over a number of years
through superintendent conferences
through superintendent meetings so we
continue to say to them and we have
grant money grant funds available to you
if you have an issue that needs to be
remediated so while they weren't
required to report that information to
us we were very active in terms of
pushing this out to them
and we work directly i mean i know you
know amy clark as well works very
closely with the facilities folks to
make sure that they as well know as
we're going through kind of the building
inspection process they know that uh you
know there are if if there's any barrier
to
you know remediation that we have
solutions to that
um but if i could just follow up i don't
want to over promise i mean we are not
staff to
have a comprehensive regulatory
oversight of this law and all these
entities for these provisions we are
getting the word out we're getting the
data responding to high levels
but an ideal world we'd have several
staff in a database that takes the flow
of data sends out letters requiring
notification making schools prove they
did a notification
showing the schools they have violations
making them show they have corrective
action
we just can't do that with a federally
funded three-fourth of the time staff
position so we are really trying to
leverage our partnerships with hhs and
department of education and our
contractor to do the best we can
we there were fiscal notes to all these
bills and the funds weren't there but i
think we're still doing a very effective
job with the approach we're taking
so i mean
i think schools are great too
but i'm not hearing that beyond
your confidence and the fact that you
know people who work in schools
that we're actually getting reports from
this schools
that they are remediating
a problem that we know poisons hundreds
of children
in new hampshire is there more
legislative action we're going to need
to take to require that when the schools
that have
right now 15 parts per billion
starting in
you know a few months
hopefully it'll be five parts per
billion are we going to need to
require
the schools to report to in des that
they have remediated
the problems
we can keep establishing requirements
for schools and child care facilities on
what they have to do
but if you want des to be able to say
like we can for water systems here's
exactly where each water system stands
they collected the sample here's the
result here's the notification here's
the treatment that was installed if you
want to do that we're going to need more
than
a year-to-year part-time person funded
to administer the program
and i'm just trying to be transparent
with you i mean we're trying as hard as
we can trying to find resources
to implement the law but there's
limitations um when there's funding
limitations
a lot of requirements without
really a lot of budgeting and financing
for it at this point and so we're i'm
trying essentially saying we're doing
the best we can i can't over promise
based on the resources that we we have
been given for this
statute
thank you yeah i would i would hope that
you could convince your leadership
in des to uh request that for the 2425
budget
i mean there's obviously a line item
there for it
and so
i would ask that you
pursue that with uh
with leadership thank you we can pretty
much draw from our fiscal notes and put
it right in there okay well
then we gotta move up but that's a
anyhow hopefully we'll see some um
movement on this
okay uh
are there any questions on the uh
dashboard
uh did you have a question
oh
okay
it was nothing on the dashboard
okay thank you
um
the dashboard is also
an area that um
we will try to uh to work on over the
summer
gonna be a busy summer for some of us
okay
fis 22 192 health and human services
so
representative leitchman
thank you madam chair
thanks for appearing
so if you go to page three item c
um
i believe this whole item was addressed
by fiscal back in december there's 27
roughly 28 million dollars
and
further down and see it talks about um
the department is working with cms to
obtain approvals for
distributing the 2.8 million i kind of
thought
that was part of the request
in december is that like a separate item
now or
good morning thank you for the question
uh representative leishman for the
record henry lipman uh
medicaid director i'm just referring to
a letter for a moment oh no problem no
problem
this is the school component
this is a school that's the same
yeah
is that
the chris santaniello associate
commissioner are you asking about the
2.8
there's in c there's two
it's the 2.8 for
private duty nursing
yes i guess i'm asking so the managed
care organizations
and the
private nurses etc have those funds been
distributed yet or
how is that working out because it was a
concern back in december that
the case managers weren't receiving
money and i'm just curious whether they
have received any of that 2.8 million or
is this
you're still working with cms to get
that money
so thank you for the question
clarifications because now i'm tracking
what you're asking about um so the the
approximate 28 million that was for
managed care
um we got approval for that subsequent
to um and i think it was probably in
january
for the for the approach then we needed
to get approval for the claiming
methodology meaning how we actually
would um draw the money down
we it took us until um
we thought we had had clearance based on
regional office approval um
and mid-march but then we got a stop if
you will from the
from the central office
we cleared that up recently
i think it was the end of april
we're now in process of if you remember
part of the process is getting
the agencies to sign an attestation
recognizing that this is one-time money
and etcetera and that how they're going
to use it were um i'd say by the end of
the month that 28 million
um assuming that the agencies have
submitted and all their attestations
will be out the door
it's we had probably a we expected that
was going to happen in march but we got
held up with respect to the claiming
methodology approval
and that's why today we're just
reporting generally that we haven't used
the whole 72 that we came in for we do
expect that will all the money that we
talked about um
being within there will go out with
respect to the case managers which i
think was senator guida had that
question in particular and possibly
yourself
we have received approval under the
appendix k authority
just this earlier this month and we have
submitted the state plan to be able to
also
do the cfi case managers
um i think we're going to be able to get
that money out in the month of june
so the 2.8 million roughly will be you
think sometime in june right okay thanks
thanks madam chair
so we'll follow up on that in our july
meeting
represent edwards
uh thank you i i was with gaida and uh
leishman curious about the case managers
and i
i think i recall
that
the department said this would be
resolved by april
or may and now we're into june what
could is my memory faulty are we
slipping what's what's going on there
based on what we understood at the time
when we came in that was i think a
reasonable time frame in fact we thought
it was reasonable until mid-march until
we got what we we understood to be an
approval to draw the federal funds for
this
and then we got a second
just as we were about to pull the
trigger we got a second email saying hey
wait a minute we want to look at
not only new hampshire but how other
states are doing this
and so we had to wait until
they the central office at cms looked at
it and we you know we had it we felt we
always had a solid methodology and we
got the green light as soon as possible
and we were on them pretty much uh i met
with the
the head of cms financial management
group the head of the managed care group
um you know on a telephone conversation
to make sure it wasn't something
specific to new hampshire and it wasn't
um they just wanted to make sure they
were doing consistently among states and
it just took us about another
45 to 60 days longer than anticipated as
a result of that
are there any further questions
okay on this report
on this report
thank you
um
on the uh paragraph three medicaid to
schools providers i think fiscal
committee approved
a request
where the school's part of it was just a
couple of words in a three or four page
document
seven million dollars in federal money
was was being moved
i've since talked to
um
miss tilly
and she says that
this program is going to require 1
million
i'm i'm curious if if we're talking
about the same program or if there's a
different program she's she's trying to
set out an rfa
so that the schools can say whether or
not they want to participate in this
program
is that what this is or is this
something different thank you for the
question it is something different um
schools today can
claim under certified public
expenditures
additional you know matching funds what
we've been doing all along is the
enhanced 6.2 percent um that has existed
um we've passed that along then this
hcbs the home and coming based service
component we can pass on an extra 10 for
rehab oriented services and so we're
we're in the process of putting that
money out too and i think that will be
out before uh june as well
okay so
um
in miss tilly's effort
she's thinking that about three or four
schools in the major population centers
are going to expand behavioral health
services in schools
is this to i'm sorry to what extent
is this related to that program are are
these for services offered in the school
or
or something else so for this particular
program it's only goes for services that
were provided between april 1 of 21 and
march 31st of of 22. so
if it's not online yet it's not subject
to what's in this
request
or in this report
all right thank you
are there any further questions
seeing none thank you very much
[Music]
fis22193 dealing with the lottery
commission
i was um
particularly upset that
scratch tickets are down
um
for some reason or other
uh
mr mcintyre told me not to worry about
that but
it uh it affects the
uh it does have an effect on our
education trust fund
not a lot but with some
so
thank you for uh for coming today
uh you're uh your mike's not on thank
you thank you for having me jim durris
the cfo for the lottery commission
um
being the cfo i sometimes look at things
differently than charlie does he's he's
sales side i'm accounting side
uh but i you know the obviously we're
having a lot of financial pressures it's
not a non-essential item gas prices
grocery prices and everything certainly
you're gonna have an effect
but when you really look at the overall
picture
um
we're still up overall for the year
um this is really the first quarter
we're feeling that pressure i do expect
to see it in this upcoming quarter as
well
uh but when you look at also over a you
know two year
uh we're still overall up year-to-date
100 million dollars in revenues i mean
excuse me sales during a two-year span
so yes we saw record highs last year can
you sustain those record highs forever
of course not
so we're seeing a little bit of
flattening out but in my my opinion
that's what really what we're seeing is
just a little correction and flattening
out
over the pressed
incredible growth to over the last two
years
okay so i will watch it next quarter
very good okay thank you very much
are there any other questions
okay seeing none
all right appreciate it i'm sorry that
you were here for so long
okay nice air-conditioned building what
the heck
okay um we're now going to turn to uh
department of education
uh arpa funding update
welcome commissioner
good morning again
[Music]
so we are handing out to you right now
two documents one is a several slides
that we'll use to facilitate our
conversation
as well as a handout
that details
information by individual school
districts that we assumed individuals
might have an interest in
what i can tell you as well is that
you uh called for us to come before you
i was like a month ago or something like
that and i had been hoping my fingers
were crossed because we're in the
process of building an interactive
website that will just make all of this
information transparent and through data
visualization people can just click and
they'll be able to see what's going on
at the state level at the district level
in terms of the use of the funds so that
will be forthcoming we are close to
getting that done but we weren't there
yet um i needed one more month but i
just figured i'd come in and give you
your update now
if you turn to the first slide which is
on the back of the cover slide there
this is just to level set you in terms
of the funds um that we are bringing to
you today
in fact the and um we might have
expanded the scope of this a little bit
we could have expanded it more but i
wanted to be as responsive as i can the
request was for information relative
relative to arp funds but there's a lot
of other grants that are out there so
we've so what i brought to you today was
sr1 which is often referred to as the
cares act
sr2 which is often referred to as
carissa and then arp esser which was the
specific request that you made to us
there are other funds out there as well
we have received we received 45 million
dollars through the initial
covert relief funds that the state
received
we also received funding relative to
idea
so we received about 10 million dollars
of pass-through funds relative to idea
which is not on here as well as we
received about three million dollars for
um homeless funds but today we are
focusing on what i think was the main
thing that you were looking for which
was kind of the esser related funds
which is the cares carissa and
arp funds
and you can see the award amounts that
we have there
the amounts that are allocated to the
lea so it's a 90 pass-through grant so
basically 90 of those funds pass through
to the districts and we'll give you some
information on that we're also going to
give you some information today on the
10 state level activities as well
and then you can see the amount and and
really what i wanted to describe to you
is kind of the process that it goes
through so what happens is a school so
we get the grants
then we make the allocations to the
schools in our gms which is our grant
management system
the schools then go in and complete a
budget for how they're going to use
those funds
that budget is approved in terms of
whether those funding activities the
budgeted activities are authorized
activities under the grant
once those budgets are approved then the
schools go out and they spend those
funds after they spend those funds then
they submit the documentation to
indicate that they've spent their funds
according to their budget
that approval process kicks off a
a payment to them and so it comes out
through the typical state payment
process and simultaneously what that
does is allows us to draw down those
funds from the g5 system at the federal
government level so that we reimburse
the state so we simultaneously push the
funds out and we draw the funds down
from the federal government and so that
is the process that happens um and i can
tell you have a question go ahead yes
yeah
so you allocate the money
the schools have to spend their own
money
correct we have we are a reimbursement
grant system which is the way that most
of the states operate and so this is
reimbursement yes i just wanted to be
sure
that that's what it was it is
reimbursement right so right they budget
it they spend it they report that
they've spend it then they get
reimbursed for those funds
thank you great
um and then what you'll find is that um
sometimes with so when they budget the
funds it doesn't mean it's necessarily a
locked in number they're able to
oftentimes reopen anytime they want they
can reopen the grant so they might have
planned like we're going to budget these
funds on x activity they go out and they
do a bid on that activity and they
realize it's going to cost us less so
then what happens is the the
the grant gets returned to us is what
it's called it's kind of an odd name but
it's returned to us
to then so it's now they're able to
update the budget status and then it
gets reapproved and then they're off and
doing their updated budget so so there's
a lot of pushing back and forth as the
budgets change
okay
any questions on that slide
so on the next slide
what i did is
outline for the leas
some of the common uses
based on the how they've been spending
those funds
and i indicated both the budgeted as
well as the amount that's spent to date
and the reason i did that is because
there's a lot of stuff budgeted that
hasn't been spent and spent means when
the state
reimburses to the lea not necessarily
when they spend it themselves so that's
what spent means
and so you can see that the big
categories are salaries and benefits
construction and maintenance equipment
and technology
supplies non-instructional which would
be primarily your coveted response type
supplies and then support services as
well
and then you can see where they have
spent across those various categories
you can see that there's a little bit of
difference software licensing is in the
top five
relative to spend but it is not in terms
of the budgeted but that is something
that oftentimes when you're buying
software you have those upfront
licensing fees so those probably just
came through a little bit more quickly
and and that is reflected in that
so these are the places where those
funds have been budgeted by the schools
to be used
and this basically this was a top five
and we cut it off at top five because
there was a fairly substantive
gap between number five like i'd rather
than go give you the top 10. it's kind
of like this was a natural breaking
point event you know we have all of the
data all the way down to the smallest
one but i just thought that was a good
place to break it so that you can see
where the numbers are
i think for example on the spend is the
next lowest level was like a million
yeah
so it went from like five to down to a
million so we thought that was a pretty
big jump and we cut it off there
and then on is that any other questions
on that page
and so then on the left yes it appears
we have one okay
go ahead thank you
uh using using the money on salaries and
benefits and being one-time money
type things do we
see a problem coming on down down the
road in the local communities when
they're
using it for ongoing expenses yeah so we
have been encouraging our districts to
recognize that this is one-time money
depending on which grant the last grant
is going to expire on september 24
and unless it's extended by the federal
government but even so we're encouraging
everybody to work to utilize the funds
by that current uh finalized date so
some of that salary and benefits is
going to be associated with the current
teacher force that they have it could be
overtime could be stipends could be you
know uh bonuses to try and retention
bonuses or something like that some of
it is interventionists that are being
hired to be able to
respond to some of the the learning
disruption that's taking place so um
in in theory
uh senator if uh the learning loss is
caught up over the period of the grant
then you wouldn't need that learning
interventionist at that point in time
because you've made up the deficit that
resulted from coven and so that wouldn't
have to continue
but certainly it is something that all
districts need to be paying attention to
in terms of making sure that we haven't
created a cliff for ourselves um and and
quite frankly there was a bit of a cliff
through the if you go back to the
through 2008-2012 recession there was a
lot of federal funds that came in and
that did result in some of that cliff
effect thank you
and then on the last page this is the
state funding so what the the the way
the grant is laid out it allows uh the
state to set aside a certain percentage
for administration of the grant and then
it includes what's referred to as sl or
state level activities
some of the grants in particular under
the arp funds the grant specifies how
we're supposed to use it like we have
we're required to spend at least uh 20
percent on learning loss we're supposed
to spend five percent on summer
programming and five percent on
after-school programming so they narrow
down the scope of what we can do and so
in here what i did is i just outlined a
number of the contracts that we've
entered into relative to
various state-level activities uh the
goal of the state-level activities was
try and invest in programs that are
universal in terms of supporting the
schools
and not supplanting activities that they
may have
so for example the ilearn which is a
canvas learning management system that
was made available to all the schools
many of our schools were using that
system already so
to senator um daniel's point so we were
able to just you know supplement that uh
the cost of their learning management
system during for several years but that
would then transfer back over
discovery education is universal
you know curricular high quality
instructional materials for students so
essentially saying you know every
student in new hampshire
you know
has a high quality learning management
system which means that they can
organize the teachers can organize the
instruction in an effective way
and then fill that with high quality
instructional materials so students
whether you live in bedford or in a
less affluent community you're going to
have access to high quality
instructional materials
eens is a bit of an odd name that is
emergency relief to our non-public
schools
so there's a separate category of
funding that we pass through to ends
many of you are familiar with the
learning pod program that we've stood up
the rekindling curiosity is our summer
camp program yes every student is our
tutoring program how we've got another
tutoring program that we're going to be
bringing online again these are
universal programs to help the teachers
in the schools across the state who are
trying to work with students who have
learning loss
one of the things that i think is
interesting as well is the way that
these grants kind of rolled out
the first funds came to us in may of
2020. uh that would have been the gear
one and the esser one funds and
obviously the circumstance of the
pandemic kind of evolved over time uh
and so to see i can tell you quite
frankly sometimes there were decisions
that you made in may of 2020 that if you
knew where you would be 18 months later
like you didn't know where you were
going to be maybe you would have done
something a little bit differently
so i don't know if there's i can go
through all the lists and explain the
various programs or if everybody's all
set then or i can answer specific
questions yeah i i just want to make
sure
that
doe has contracted all of these things
is that what i heard you say that's
correct and then it's
given down to the school system correct
and then we pass through to the schools
okay
uh represent leashman
thank you madam chair
thanks for your
information
uh
i was hoping maybe in the future that
you could give us what like gear eens
esther all these things mean because a
lot of it i guess looks greek to me but
so actual titles yes so what they
actually are
some of them
it's pretty straightforward like i mean
and i i may not even get them all
correct because i'm so used to using it
forward to you it's not necessarily
straightforward to uh
to do people that are not familiar with
all of those weird acronyms in d.o.e
right so yeah it just send it to us no
problem yeah
but as an example like gear is
governor's emergency education relief
fund
so they all mean something associated
with that yeah
and just to follow up if i could have
made them chair
on the
allocations and budgeted spent i'm just
kind of curious because some of these
are i'll just take dairy cooperative as
an example on page one
allocated 3.5
budgeted 3.4
approved 3.4 and there's nothing can you
just tell me what grant you're looking
at
uh that was there's all three grants
right i'm sorry uh
easter two
yes or two got it okay
on very cooperative 3.5 right budgeted
and i just kind of curious you got the
budgeted approved and yet nothing has
been paid is there why has nothing been
paid for instance to that school
district so it could be that they've
simply not um
you know either spent it's not paid at
this point because they haven't asked
for reimbursement once they ask for
reimbursement then it will show up in
the paid column but it could be that
they are you know maybe they're
allocating those funds for a
construction project and they haven't
started yet and so once they get started
then we'll get the invoices for that all
right thanks
thanks madam chair uh thank you
uh
i
i'm also
when does the s for one money run out
to one expires in september 22.
so like that's three months away that is
three months away okay
do the schools understand that they do
we continuously are providing that
information and reporting to them yeah
well obviously they
okay because they're pretty i mean you
know spent they've already drawn down
you know 30 out of 33 and it could be
that they're sitting on reimbursements
and those are gonna you know in
september we'll get a whole bunch of
bills to put to process okay okay
okay and melissa is just pointing out uh
that many of them are using that for
summer programming and and i have to
apologize i failed to introduce who was
with me today so melissa white and by
the way i'm happy to introduce her is
our uh newly minted uh director of the
division of learner support
and jessica lescarbo is our program
administrator for our kobe relief funds
okay thank you and i apologize for not
introducing them in the beginning no no
problem i'm apologizing to them oh okay
that's good that's good um
i realize that our esra 3 money
that doesn't expire until 24
24 so
i understand that the school systems
supposedly are
spending their one one and two money
and then will
that is what we're encouraging yes yeah
okay
all right
and then all of this just shows
where they
where they are
right and then i just broke down by each
grant you have a consolidated is the
first page of the hand the school
district handout and then a separate
page for each of the individual grants
if you want to see it by school district
okay
so you you allocate this then they use
this money correct whatever it is and
what your allocation formula
it's basic we get the allocations from
the federal government it's based on a
title one formula
oh so the same title one formula that
same formula that's used to allocate
title one funds to the schools is the
same formula so that's how the esra
money was passed through to the school
pass through based on title one yes okay
i didn't know that sorry about that yeah
that's quite all right
okay are there any further questions
seeing none we will uh i thank you for
this and
i'm sure we'll have an opportunity for
an update later on that would be great
and hopefully the website will be online
at that point in time and you can just
go browse it yeah like i have nothing
else to do
okay department of transportation
looking forward to
hearing about this um
oh you don't have to leave you might
want to hear about diode
you know
you probably have a pothole in your road
someplace so all right nope no fixing
for you
i know they'll be watching online this
is must-see tv so you know
as much as you make fun you would not
believe
the number of people
that
tune into this we have an engaged
electorate yes we do yes we do madam
chair uh thank you for inviting us here
i guess good afternoon to other members
of the committee as well i'm andre
barrier i'm the deputy commissioner and
i send the regards of our commissioner
uh sheehan who can't be her
unfortunately she is under the weather
but i'm sure she is watching
so good afternoon to commissioner
sheehan out there
i also brought our director of finance
marie mullen who's to my left and she'll
be talking about specific numbers as
well as
representatives from our aviation and
transit bureaus
who are right behind me and they're here
to answer any specific questions about
spending in those areas
of their responsibility uh but overall
our arpa cares and chris expenditures
are all responsive to the very real uh
decrease in uh ridership passenger
volume
uh as well as impacts to our highway
fund that we experienced through the
pandemic
on the transit side were roughly
two-thirds of the passenger volume that
we were pre-pandemic that's very uneven
there are certain segments that are as
low as a third of the ridership still
on the aviation side tsa tells us we're
about 88
of pre-pandemic passenger volume that
seems to be recovering much quicker
but each of these uh types of money is
allocated in slightly different ways and
at slightly different levels of
expenditure so for details on that i'm
going to pass it to my colleague marie
mullen
wait could we hang on just second sure
are we expecting
ridership
on buses to increase
with the gas
traditionally uh madam chair that's what
we see uh and we met not too uh long ago
with uh leadership from boston express
that was a specific question i asked
them is the previous iteration of this
really back in the 08 time frame what
did you see
in terms of ridership and it was a
dramatic increase
so
there have been some trend lines that
are encouraging um we
you never hope for high gas prices but
the one area that it can benefit is
transit ridership so we do
uh hope and expect to see an impact from
that whether it goes all the way is just
remains to be seen and we'll we'll see
over time
thank you
all right thank you and good afternoon
so the first page of our presentation
is a review of our federal highway fund
so these funds were apportioned
to the state of new hampshire based on
the federal highway allocation so
as division ii is well aware the state
of new hampshire has the lowest
allocation of federal highway funds in
the country so again our stimulus funds
were the lowest in the country but we
were apportioned 41 million dollars and
those on division two also remember the
during the budget process
these funds were budgeted in our 2223
budget to supplant highway funds
as the highway funds had some
significant revenue shortages there
so
those were input to cover our highway
maintenance costs so approximately 41
million over 22 and 23. and so you can
see here what we've expended so far
through fiscal year 22
is about 31 million dollars and we
anticipate the rest of the remaining
balance to be drawn down uh in the
within the first quarter of fiscal year
23 and then we'll have
drawn down the full 41 million of these
this allocation
of chris of funds any questions on the
federal highway piece of this
yes represent senator rosenwald thank
you i've had constituents asking me
recently
when concord coach is going to restart
their bus service to new york city
and i wonder if
any of you know the answer
in the public transportation
administration
so that commissioner sheehan can hear it
at home
the only reason you need to use the mic
is because it is on the streaming
streaming
and if you're not using the mic
out there they can't hear you i
understand yes um
yes
coach
it is it is on their radar they have
plans to
reinstate that service to new york city
they don't have a
i'm not aware of a definite date
um
they are
they're hedging that against a lot of
other
their core service what they consider
going down to boston and
uh but it is it is in the works as far
as i know thank you i hope you can
try to pin them down on yeah we'll do
our data and later we'll follow up and
get a more definite answer as well sure
thank you madam chair and if i could add
one thing to that answer and that is uh
it's a good i'm sorry but you don't need
to stay up there
there is a kind of a multi-headed hydra
here right so it's not just decreased
ridership that we're dealing with with
our transit providers also
as the committee is well aware a
shortage of cdl drivers
and the increasingly competitive market
for those drivers in our region so those
are really the two things that that
they're struggling with and
and i know every transit provider is in
that same boat so they're they're going
to operate just as quickly as they can
as they can hire
senator d'alessandro did you have a
question
yeah yeah i would if by not by not
having complete service do we anyway
mitigate the mitigation plan that we
have in place i mean that's why these
buses are running right that's why the
federal government's paying us
we're mitigating
is there a problem with that
thanks for the question senator so yeah
i mean in terms of
i guess in the sense of if you build it
they will come if you have if you have
the service you're going to get more
ridership if you limit that service
you turn off ridership and yeah that's a
that's a dynamic that our transit
providers are well aware of which is why
they're they're trying to maximize
routes they've done a pretty darn good
job through the pandemic uh some heroic
efforts uh to maintain those routes they
continue to do so but but yeah they're
very sensitive to and cognizant of
decreased services and trying to
minimize those and and uh expand
services as quickly as they can
for the point of change certainly
because we did the golfer committee did
allocate seven million dollars of
subsidy for that program you know to
keep it going
yeah private the private inner city bus
yes thank you man yes senator
okay
oh one more yes
represent senator roosevelt um some
number of fiscal meetings ago we
approved money to pay like an incentive
to um cdl drivers
do you know what the impact or the
success of that program has been
uh i don't think that that went through
d.o.t
yeah those are those are your not for
the transit cdl's are you taught you're
talking about for for the uh we have a
cdl training program that has been uh
very successful in in training our folks
and that
and i want to make sure i'm i'm
addressing the same thing that you're
asking but this was
you're talking about the program to uh
to help our winner maintenance by
training cdl drivers and establishing
that training program no no something
different no okay i think it was an
incentive it was a program to recruit
new
cdl
applicants to increase the pool of
cdl that did not go through d.o.t it
must have gone through another agency
or another agency that so i mean we
could okay follow up but i don't believe
that's through dot yeah well maybe we
could have mr kane follow up with safety
and see
what that progress is because it
obviously they go hand in hand
thank you
all right so to continue the second page
is a summary of our
transit
funds so these
come through the federal transit
administration fta again these are
apportioned funds that come to the state
except for the the first column there
the gopher funds those were part of the
the cares act distribution that came
directly to the state as senator
rosenwald was indicating um or maybe it
was senator d'alessandro seven and a
half million from that gopher account
for the cares act funds
were provided to uh inter-city and
commuter bus operators to assist them in
resuming services and these were spent
by the deadline in december of 2020
and so you can see the three bus
operators there that receive those funds
the so this was the the your first your
gopher column is cares
yes okay thank you
and then the the next column over were
the cares act funds that were directly
apportioned to dot through the ft
through fta
and those
funds were apportioned and allocated by
state again to support operating capital
and other expenses to help mitigate the
effects of the pandemic on transit
services
funds have been utilized to supplement
losses in net operating expenses as well
as support to covert related ppe
cleaning and other
necessities during the the covid crisis
so
um and
so the cares act the krisa and the arp
funds are are all apportioned and used
for those purposes to
assist with their operating expenses as
well as ppe and those type of things and
so we have the breakdown here
by transit agency um and how much
they've received um what's programmed
and then expended and they do need to
provide
backup
to these
expenditures for these to be distributed
back to them so
um
you could see the the bottom line there
there's a reserve for future eligible
commuter
city bus services so these are funds
right now that haven't been identified
but they have to be spent by 2029 so
these are funds that are there and as
the bus providers you know we're looking
at ridership their operating expenses
um those will be allocated at that point
once it's been determined that the need
is there
and so your your column is called cares
act when is
that expire
so the cares act um
goes until expended but we believe we'll
have expended those by 2024 so the
additional 11 million dollar balance
there those will be expended in the next
two years so transportation is different
than everybody else
yeah these these were specifically
broken out in the act going directly to
fta and part of the apportioned programs
and there's several different programs
within you know the elderly no i just
met that i meant the deadline for
spending yes yes this is wonderful thank
you you're welcome
are there any other questions on the the
transit funds
okay
so then uh the next page the next five
pages are related to our
aviation and aeronautics program so
again these are funds uh directly
apportioned to this to the state and to
dot through faa through the federal
aviation administration
um this first page here details out um
cares act funds um in indicates group
one which means these were for
the 10
match that is required on federal funds
for capital projects so
in in faa capital projects five percent
match is required by the airport five
percent is paid by the state so these
funds um covered that state and local
share of those capital projects and you
can see
um the amount of money and what's been
expended and encumbered related to the
those
capital projects that have been
identified
those are cares act funds the next page
are also cares act funds
and these
we have as group two to four these were
issued for operations and maintenance
so
these are pass-through amounts that were
specified by faa allocation so they had
a
an allocation that they came up with
and each airport was given a specific
amount based on the allocation
and they've had to identify the eligible
expenses
and submit those
and once they did they they received
these funds that were apportioned by the
faa
so you can see here nearly the nearly
all of the 15.2 million has been
expended and distributed to the airports
okay if there's no questions on that one
the next um
page are chrisa act funds for from faa
um and these
were a portion for operations
maintenance and concessions
so you can see a couple of the airports
lebanon on the second line and
manchester boston regional airport on
the fifth line
have indicated that they they're look
they will be looking for some
reimbursement for concessions and then
operations maintenance on all of the
other airports
and again
they need to provide
you know eligible expenditures for these
to go out so
again it's been a portion by airport the
amount that they're eligible for and
once they provide those eligible
expenditures those will be
submitted submitted and reimbursed to
the airports
okay next page
is the arp funds and these were um also
for operations maintenance and
concessions
so the arp funds are are newer um and
what we're trying to do is draw down the
funds from the cares act and chris first
so you'll see you know not as much of
this fun these funds have been
expended to date um but um
that that's the plan and so um we have
you know
up through 2024 just to obligate the
grants and then to spend it so um these
airports um have additional allocations
that they're eligible for
as as they provide as they as we draw
down the cares in chrisa then we'll move
to these arp funds
depending on the eligibility
okay can i just
on the uh
mount washington regional airport is
that the one in freiburg or is that
someplace else
freiburg i believe this is whitefield
whitefield oh okay
so we didn't give any money to fryeburg
okay
that's fine i hope maine did
pardon
yeah i know
yes
okay
so i guess i need to uh talk to d.o.t
and maine okay thank you
and then um on the last page um again
these are arp funds and these are for
the 10 match again for the capital
grants
so this would cover the local and the
state share on these capital grants and
you can see the the grants that have
been identified to date
and you know once the the work has been
done then they would get reimbursed from
these funds
okay
so
what's going on with
roads
bridges
you know aren't we supposed to get money
for that
the the the funds related to roads and
bridges are not coveted relief funds
those were part of the um
the reauthorization of the
so that's the iija that came out so
those are not covid related funds those
are it's the
natural authorization of our
transportation
um budget so before that it was a fast
act it was a five years and then
they've now implemented the iija which
will be over the next five years
okay and that's the one
so they're no special funds
for d.o.t
no the the iija are
part of that federal reauthorization
it's part of the 10-year plan we've
brought that forward through the
legislature
and hb 2022 is now with the legislature
so all of those funds are included in
the 10-year plan and as we go through
the budget will be included in the
budget going forward okay
are there any questions yes uh represent
leishman
thanks senator chair just first uh
good job was nice to see start dates
completion days yes and
very complete reports so that was nice
um we're engineers sir so oh there you
go
so maybe a non-engineer question if i
could madam chair so i i have a friend
in the asphalt business and he said
asphalt is going up just as fast as
diesel how is that
asphalt increase impacting like your
highway projects because don't you have
like a claws in there that some of it's
based on
costs so are you still able to pave the
amount of roads that you anticipated or
is that going to impact
the amount of road mileage paved well
that's that's a great question sir and
we're seeing that and what you refer to
that's the contingency uh that's this in
every contract we're seeing uh inflation
is really
um proceeding unevenly certain things
like petroleum-based steel things like
this we're seeing significant increases
in that inflation rate and we're just
starting to see
the impact of that on bids and contracts
the contracts that exist already are
are set um and a lot of the larger
uh contractors who who do our work you
know have
big yards with a lot of materials that
they've already secured over the last
couple years
so it's going to be a very gradual
appearance of that inflation
as far as in project cost increases
things like that that's paid attention
to
at the microscopic level by our by our
project management office
and uh we're just starting to see it i
guess it's it's often referred to as a
snake you know you see it
uh you know kind of coming through the
system and and as these contractors are
you know even the smaller contractors
that don't have the luxury of large
yards full of materials and are doing
just in time procurement
they're seeing those results right now
so yeah inflation's a concern it sure is
expenditure
so i think the bottom line there is
we're keeping our fingers crossed hoping
we can pave this year
from an engineering point of view
okay
are there any further questions
i sincerely thank you and i
i appreciate all of the work that uh
that you do so thank you thank you very
much
okay
uh i just want to pass out the or give
you the
dates over the next uh
several months for our fiscal committee
meetings
so that you can uh
plan now
uh our june meeting will be in on the
17th
our july meeting will be on the 22nd
our september meeting will be on the 9th
our october meeting will be on the 14th
and our november meeting will be on the
18th
so whether you're running or not
whether you win or not
uh
whatever
i'll expect to see you here on the uh
i will expect to see you here on the
18th and any of us can fall into any of
those categories
so
uh is there any other business
for the fiscal committee
if not
thank you all and we'll see you june
17th
you